am 8 april 1997 wird die polizei im
hessischen ober mörlen zu einem
verkehrsunfall gerufen ein 5er bmw ist
gegen einen baum gerast in bagdad finden
die beamten adam boscos für den
familienvater kommt damals jede hilfe zu
spät 17 jahre trauern dann seine töchter
und seine ehefrau und glauben eben an
einen tragischen autounfall und dann
2014 die dramatische wende polizei und
staatsanwaltschaft die nehmen die
ermittlung noch einmal auf und finden
heraus der familienvater wurde per
genickschuss ermordet der ganze unfall
waren nur fingiert
[Musik]
adam scott 45 jahre alt liebender vater
unternehmer und ehemann
[Musik]
am 8 april 1997 verunglückte er tödlich
in seinem auto ein schock für alle die
ihm nahe stehen
also es ist man hat das an einem
autounfall gestorben und ja genickbruch
und
das haben wir natürlich auch geglaubt
doch ein unfall bleibt es nicht ende
2014 meldet sich plötzlich eine anonyme
zeugen die behauptet adam scott wurde
ermordet die tat als unfall getankt das
war ein schock für mich klar weil mit
dem tod mit einem unfall kann man
nach der trauerphase quasi gut umgehen
das hat niemand keiner verdient
einen menschen das leben zu nehmen
der schreckliche verdacht wird bestätigt
adam scott starb an einem genickschuss
der 17 jahre lang nicht erkannt wurde
die staatsanwaltschaft gießen ermittelt
sofort und bis heute
war auch eine große herausforderung für
uns
wir haben ballistische untersuchungen
gemacht dna untersuchung gemacht faser
untersuchung gemacht alles was
eigentlich der kriminalistisch
forensische besteckkasten her geht haben
wir unten haben wir versucht zu
unternehmen
daniela abfahrt ist als reporterin für
die bild -zeitung aktiv die seit den
ermittlungen über den mordfall berichtet
dieser unfall war mord
wer hat meinen vater hingerichtet
ich weiß wer die verdächtigen sind aber
seit drei jahren berichtet ann jeder
fahrt immer wieder über neueste
erkenntnisse hofft auf erfolg
nachdem nach so langer zeit heraus kam
dass es sich nicht so mein auto unfall
sondern um mord an den boss kurt
gehandelt hat war das natürlich für die
familie für freunde angehörige eine
unerträgliche situation bis heute
und das schlimmste daran ist eben dass
die täter noch immer frei herumlaufen
es bleiben fragen wie er war 1997 mit
adam scott im auto was hat die
sogenannte toiletten mafia mit dem mord
zu tun
und warum wurde das verfahren gegen fünf
beschuldigte trotz zeugen eingestellt
nördlich von frankfurt am main liegt die
hessische kleinstadt bad nauheim 35 km
von gießen entfernt
in diesem mehrfamilienhaus wohnt atem
post 1997 mit seiner frau und seinen
beiden töchtern tober und zieht mit 18
jahren kommt der türkische staatsbürger
nach deutschland ist bekannt als
fleißiger geschäftsmann und liebevoller
vater
die erstgeborene del bosques ort
erinnert sich
[Musik]
mein vater war ein ein sehr gebildeter
mann
sehr hilfsbereit und
er war immer für uns da für mich und für
meine schwester der hat viele sachen
mittels unternommen konzerte theater er
war einfach anders also
einfach ein toller mensch
zunächst macht adam scott eine konditor
lehre wort sich dann aber über die jahre
ein eigenes
reinigungsunternehmen auf 6
autobahnraststätten betreut er mit
seiner firma die toiletten und
duschanlagen er hat mehrere angestellte
seine jüngere tochter to back end die
damaligen arbeitsabläufe ihres vaters
noch genau
es gab ja zwei schichten erst dann
morgens immer losgefahren und dann
abends noch mal hat die mitarbeiter
abgeholt und zur raststätte gefahren ich
bin auch manchmal mit dem mitgefahren
dann haben wir uns auch mal schön
unterhalten auf den langen fahrten ja
auch am letzten tag seines lebens ist a
dem bus code auf dem weg zu einem
solchen schichtwechsel
normalerweise kam er immer von dieser
landstraße
so sollte es auch am 8 april 1997 sein
doch da kann man ja
die arbeitstage des 45 jährigen beginnen
in der regel früh am morgen seine erste
anlaufstelle an diesem tag ist nur drei
kilometer entfernt
von diesem wohnhaus aus ist er am 8
april 1997 gestartet das war in der
nacht zwischen 4 uhr und 4.30 uhr mit
seinem schwarzen bmw dann über diese
landstraße richtung seines
arbeitsplatzes zur raststätte wetterau
um 4 uhr 30 wird die örtliche polizei zu
einem tödlichen verkehrsunfall gekommen
das urteil vor ort allein unfall ohne
fremdbeteiligung
für die familie boss gurt ein schock
kuba ist noch jung als sie ihren vater
für immer verliert
es hat mir mein onkel angesagt
erst dieses jahr dass er im krankenhaus
ist und das ist halt nicht gut um ihn
aussieht
die wollten wir das hat langsam klar
machen die familie und
zwei tage später haben die mir das dann
gesagt und das war die hölle statt 14
was ist an dieser landstraße zwischen
bad nauheim und der raststätte wetterau
ober mörlen geschieht
staatsanwaltschaft gießen bild
reporterin daniela barth trifft
oberstaatsanwalt thomas rau bürger er
beschäftigt sich seit acht jahren mit
dem fall den auskommt
das war so gewesen dass die polizei
hinzugezogen hat er hat sogar auch eine
leichenschau gemacht hat dabei keine
verletzungen festgestellt die jetzt mit
dem unfallgeschehen mit dem angedachten
unfallgeschehen nicht in einklang zu
bringen gewesen wären es wird sogar noch
ein sachverständigen gutachten eingeholt
ob das fahrzeug fahrtauglich war oder ob
der etwa die bremsen kaputt waren oder
ähnliches das war alles nicht der fall
und so wurde der fall letztendlich als
normaler verkehrsunfall wir tagtäglich
in deutschland vorkommen zu den akten
gelegt wie viele türkische einwanderer
wird atemlos court in seiner alten
heimat bestattet auf einem friedhof im
türkischen izmir sein tod bleibt als
unfall in erinnerung
ende 2014 meldet sich plötzlich eine
zeugen telefonisch bei der polizei sie
behauptet ein mann namens adam wurde in
den 90er jahren ermordet wer ist die
anruferin kannte sie die mörder und kann
ihre behauptungen wahr seien
was uns hat aufhorchen lassen neben
diesen zeugenhinweis er mir dann ja erst
viele jahre später bekommen haben war
die blutspuren lage im auto ich möchte
es aus
ermittlungstaktischen der werbung nicht
genau schildern wie die fußspuren lage
war aber wenn wir dann mit diesem ex
post blick auf diese fotos geschaut
haben wir gedacht so richtig passen zu
das zu einem alleinunfall nicht und das
war dann der ansatz überhaupt um
überhaupt ein anfangsverdacht eines
tötungsdelikts bekunden zu können im
türkischen izmir wird am 12 april 2016
adamos kurz leiche exhumiert und
tatsächlich an seinem hinterkopf finden
die ermittler tödlicher kopfschuss
bunter
die akten von 1997
werfen bei der mordkommission viele
fragen auf
glaubte die polizei dass adm voskort bei
einem unfall starb obwohl der wagen kaum
beschädigt war warum wurde auch der
beifahrer airbag ausgelöst wenn adm doch
allein im wagen gewesen sein sollte
und wie kann es zum tödlichen kopfschuss
der solange hunden fb
wir gehen eigentlich von folgen tat
ablauf aus der del bosque wollte an
diesem morgen zu seiner arbeitsstelle
fahren zu irgendeinem zeitpunkt muss ein
oder zwei täter müssen zu gestiegen sein
das fahrzeug vielleicht kannte er sie
vielleicht haben sie ihn überwältigt das
ist natürlich reine spekulation und dann
im bereich dieses baumes wurde dieser
vermeintliche verkehrsunfall passiert
ist muss es dann zur schussabgabe
gekommen sein und zwar dergestalt dass
sie ihm ins knie geschossen worden ist
also wir gehen von der tötung von hinten
aus und dass ich dann die täter von
diesem unfallort entfernt haben dass
unsere prothese
bubacks damals schwer krebskranke mutter
nihal muss ihren töchtern die furchtbare
nachricht 17 jahre nach dem
vermeintlichen unfall überbringen also
er ist auf jeden fall zum zweiten mal
gestorben
nur schlimmer das sage ich ja auch mal
dass es doch noch viel schlimmer war
weil den unfall den akzeptierst du aber
ein boarding also das kannst du nicht
akzeptieren und ja es war viel schlimmer
wie viel schlimmer
bild reporterin daniela abfahrt besucht
mit dem bus kurz tochter noch mal die
landstraße an der ihr vater vor 25
jahren ermordet worden
aber wir sind jetzt am tatort wo war das
denn jetzt genau
also ungefähr da ist es passiert das war
früher natürlich anders aus da gab es
den zaun nicht da waren mehr bäume genau
also ich komme auch nicht mehr gerne
hierher anfangs habe ich noch blumen
gebracht und seitdem ich auch weiß dass
es kein unfall war sondern nord
komme ich sehr ungern also dass auch
wenn ich hier vorbei fahren muss ist
unangenehm als einfach weh tut
was sind das für gefühle die da gerade
in dir sind ja wenn ich hier vorbei dann
stelle ich mir halt vor wie das passiert
sein muss was für eine angst gehabt
haben muss in dem moment wo jemand bei
ihm im auto sitzt ihn mit einer
schusswaffe bedroht also
denke ich wieder zu tief und denkt an
seine gedanken hat er schon an mich
gedacht an meine mutter an meine
schwester sollte gedanken kommen wir
dann in den kopf und was für eine angst
mein vater auch gehabt haben muss um
sein leben um uns dass er uns alleine
lässt sozusagen also es sind
schreckliche gedanken die man einfach
hatte man hier wenn ich hier
vorbeifahren oder hier bin ja die machen
mich einfach todtraurig
auch erinnerungen an aussagen ihrer
mittlerweile verstorbenen mutter
bekommen plötzlich eine völlig neue
bedeutung als kind habe ich das nicht so
wahrgenommen aber später hat mir das hat
meine mutter auch wohlstand und älter
geworden bin erzählt dass mein vater
schon bedroht worden ist dass man ihm
was antut wenn er die raststätten die
toilettenanlagen da nicht irgendwie
teilt weitergibt
in den neunziger jahren ist die
sogenannte toiletten mafia aktiv
vermeintliche reinigungskräfte
kassierten auf raststätten kleingeld für
die toilettennutzung doch das geld geht
an die kriminellen hintermänner wurde
adam scott opfer dieser leute er
verdiente mit den sechs von ihm
betreuten raststätten bis zu 40.000
d-mark rund 20.000 euro im monat wollte
die kriminelle konkurrenz ihn
ausschalten 2014 meldet sich eine
anonyme anruferin bei der polizei und
behauptet dem bus kurt wurde ermordet
ich kann es einfach immer noch nicht
begreifen und verstehen es war ein
schock für mich
im türkischen izmir wird 2016 atem
boscos leichnam exhumiert und
tatsächlich die ermittler finden eine
tödliche kopfschuss bundes schnell kommt
der verdacht auf dass die in den
neunzigern aktive toiletten mafia
dahinter steckt kriminelle kassierten
auf deutschlands raststätten kleingeld
für toiletten noch so
das geschäft war lukrativ
war dämpfer scott den kriminellen als
konkurrent im weg der airbus hatte mit
der toiletten mafia die es damals wohl
gegeben hat überhaupt nichts zu tun aber
er hatte ein geschäftsfeld nämlich die
bewirtschaftung von toilettenanlagen im
bereich von raststätten insbesondere an
autobahnen das war so wie wir das jetzt
im nachhinein ermitteln konnten wohl
relativ hart umkämpftes geschäft weil
man dort auch genügend geld verdienen
konnte und das ist auch der bereich in
dem wir die motivlage sehen weil der
brustkorb war da ein sehr talentierter
geschäftsmann gewesen und wir können uns
vorstellen haben auch entsprechende
hinweise darauf dass dieser dieses
tötungsdelikt aus diesem milieu kommt
aber warum hat damals bei der
untersuchung des vermeintlichen
unfallopfers niemand eine kopfwunde
bemerkt notarzt und rechtsmedizin waren
schließlich vor ort erstmal muss man
ehrlich zu sich selbst sein und erkennen
dass die polizeibeamten da ja nicht
sensibilisiert waren für ein
tötungsdelikt wenn sie zu einem
stinknormalen verkehrsunfall gerufen
werden und zwar sogar so dass der
medizin ja auch keine äußerlichen
verletzungen festgestellt hat und
wir gehen auch davon aus dass der oder
die täter eine kleinkalibrige waffe
verwandt haben und den nachdem bostock
mittels genickschuss getötet haben und
da kann es sein beispielsweise gerade
wenn man eine starke behaarten kopfhaut
hat das ist nur zu ganz wenig blut
austritt kommt und wenn das projektil
aus dem mund fliegt dann hat man
beispielsweise vorne keine verletzungen
das ist eine verkettung sage ich ganz
ehrlich von unglücklichen umständen so
war es damals gewesen
überall mattli wendet sich in ihrer
verzweiflung an einen anwalt möchte
endlich gewissheit wer für den mord an
ihrem vater verantwortlich ist
strafverteidiger julian heiß fallen
unzulänglichkeiten bei den ermittlungen
auf dieses erste was hätte auffällig
sein müssen ist der beifahrer airbag der
aktiviert war und das geht nur wenn ein
gewisses licht gewisses gewicht am
beifahrersitz vorhanden ist das in
sensoren drin das heißt es muss jemand
beifahrersitz gesessen haben und alleine
dies hätte den schluss zwingend zu
lassen müssen dass mehrere leute
zumindest eine weitere person im
fahrzeug an gewesen sein musste und dem
wurde überhaupt nicht nachgegangen
gerade adam boscos bmw von damals wird
für die ermittler zum wichtigsten
spurenträger doch die suche danach
gestaltet sich schwierig
in dem fahrzeug hat ja die tat
stattgefunden
dort könnte man eine vielzahl von spuren
finden dna faserspuren blutspuren aber
auch natürlich teile des geschosses was
sie abgefeuert worden sein muss
unsere ermittlungen haben uns dann nach
polen geführt weil dieses fahrzeug
später viele jahre nach der tat nach
polen verkauft worden ist ist dort aber
ausgeschlachtet worden und deswegen war
es für sich nicht mehr vorhanden
überall matti verlangt akteneinsicht und
erkennt dass es tatverdächtige aus dem
umfeld ihres vaters gibt als ich
erfahren habe wer die tatverdächtigen
sind war das ein sehr großer schock für
mich weil
den einen oder anderen kennt man und
also um das zu verdauen das zu verstehen
also da habe ich auch einige zeit
gebraucht es war ganz schlimm auch doch
belastbare zeugenaussagen und beweise
gibt es nicht die anklage gegen die fünf
beschuldigten wird fallen gelassen
wir haben ja mehrere beschuldigte und
diese zeugenaussagen kamen aus dem
umfeld des beschuldigten der
beschuldigten haben wir freunde
ehefrauen um so weiter und so fort und
diese sind dann wieder zurückrudert von
ihrem aussagegehalt ich erkläre mir
dadurch dass von dritter seite hier
eingewirkt wurde um die zeugen
dahingehend zu bestimmen wie sie
aussagen sollen es habe ja auch viel
versucht aber
es ist zum verzweifeln geworden ja das
ist zum verzweifeln man kommt nicht
weiter und wir bräuchten einen zeugen
der vor gericht tatsächlich mal die
wahrheit bekundet und dazu steht was er
sagt ich verstehe es halt nicht der eine
wichtige zeuge verspricht es mir
mehrmals und am ende hält er sein
versprechen auch sie blz ältere
schwester kann nicht nachvollziehen dass
sich mitwisser nicht offenbaren so wie
die frau die 2014 telefon durch den
entscheidenden hinweis bei der polizei
gab dass sie einfach alles erzählt meine
es klingt ja nicht sie hat angerufen sie
hat unser leben quasi dadurch ruiniert
ja also jetzt mal hart gesagt und das
bringt alles nichts wenn dann müsst ihr
die komplette wahrheit sagen damit wir
endlich auch mal unser frieden damit wir
endlich auch mit diesem thema
abschließen kann die ganzen zeugen die
beim staatsanwalt oder polizeiaussagen
müssen dann auch noch vor gerichten
nochmal aussahen und das war eben nicht
zu erwarten weil die meisten zeugen dann
gesagt haben wir machen von unserem
aussageverweigerungsrecht gebrauch oder
widersprüchliche angaben gemacht haben
also das macht mir den als hat manchmal
schwerer zu wissen
ja die sind immer auf freiem fuß vor
meiner tür
es ist immer wenn ich rausgehe immer so
eine wut und angst auch da diese person
zu sehen also nicht angst vor der person
aber einfach vom von mir selber wie ich
reagieren werde was für eine wut ich in
dem moment empfinden werde
ja zu wissen dass einer der verdächtigen
in meiner nähe wohnt ist schlimm schlimm
25 jahre nach adams ermordung suchen die
ermittler natürlich noch immer nach
hinweisen möchten die täter endlich
hinter gitter bringen
diese ungewissheit die mit diesen fällen
für die angehörigen verbunden sind
diesen sehr quälend und diese qualen
nehmen wir als ermittlungsbehörde aus
der ernst und mord verjährt nie deswegen
werden diese ermittlung auch niemals
eingestellt
die polizei will ich sie dir hat am 8
april 1997 etwas verdächtiges an der
straße zwischen bad nauheim und der
autobahnraststätte wetterau beobachtet
wem ist an der raststätte selbst etwas
aufgefallen wer weiß wer mit dem hotspot
1997 streit gehabt hat ihn sogar bedroht
hat und wer ihn ermordet hat
ich bin sicher dass da draußen noch
einige sind die mehr wissen du mein
vater war immer ein guter mensch der war
er war gut zu jedem und tut mir tut ihm
doch den gefallen redet doch sagt doch
das was ihr wisst ich möchte einfach
gerechtigkeit für mein vater auch die
bild reporterin hofft dass zeugen von
damals ihr schweigen brechen
ich wünsche mir für die familie von adam
scott aus ganzem herzen dass dieser fall
geklärt wird auch nach so einer langen
zeit das mit besser dass tatverdächtige
sich doch noch einmal äußern dass die
ermittlungen wieder ins rollen kommen
helfen sie den fall dem boss court
endlich aufzuklären
hinweise an das polizeipräsidium gießen
unter 0641
7006 0
[Musik]